Ces scientifiques ont découvert 1 chose étonnante
et même, pour tout dire, tout à fait extraordinaire.
Il existe 1 musique
que l'immense majorité des fœtus,
quelle que soit leur nationalité,
préfère à toutes les autres,
c'est la musique classique.
Et il y a encore plus incroyable.
Et il y a encore plus incroyable, 91% !
Oui, vous m'entendez bien,
91% des futurs bébés préfèrent 1
musique classique, en particulier 91%.
Mais quelle musique peut-elle être assez belle
pour être élue par les futurs bébés
de manière aussi unanime ?
Et dès le 1ère tour,
si j'ose dire.
Cette musique, chers amis,
la voilà
pour toi !
Oh oh ! Oh !
Oui, cette musique, c'est Mozart !